this is what I imagine heaven might look
like Wow
peeking behind the scenes of the Costume
Institute induces fashion euphoria
better cut our you might have dolls shag
this installation studio is where
curator in charge
Andrew Bolton is preparing this year's
Met Gala exhibit camp notes on fashion
what is camp campus is a very difficult
term to to defines which is what I think
part of its power it's too much like too
many sequins too many ruffles too many
feathers dr. Wayne the Mets basement are
more than 33,000 outfits this is where
we store on 18th century dresses and it
was all in 19th century dresses as well
and accessories look at the detail
they're sort of like the Polka jewel of
shoes representing five continents and
seven centuries of fashion this is a
dress from 1765 it's said to have
belonged to one of Antoinette's
ladies-in-waiting Bolton says the goal
here is to record the evolution of
fashion and its artistic development
fashion Tamizh is a complete reflection
design guys it's a barometer to our
times so it's a great indicator social
as well as artistic history and just
like most museums there's no touching
just this we do sweat on your pants and
absolutely no one is allowed to wear any
of the garments here this is
unbelievable so silicon is extremely
difficult to conserve it's really to do
with keeping the temperature levels even
and conserving centuries-old items and
complex materials like silicon or
plastic
everybody thinks plastic lasts forever
and unfortunately it does not especially
in fashion his wear Conservatoire serous
Couture oh and her laboratory colleagues
come to the rescue
we do have different kinds of
temperatures and humidity 'z that we can
store our plastics in all of the
different materials expand and contract
at different rates this is complicated
stuff this isn't just fashion this is
science
Scutaro says her team's work can be seen
as fashion surgery when the fabric is so
brittle we end up having to do an
adhesive treatment which is essentially
what it sounds like gluing it back
together this area is so restricted that
a few lucky visitors are usually PhD
students they have an extraordinary
collection of just about every period of
clothing or costume designers like
Catherine Martin you get to put white
gloves on and you get to go through all
the drawers it's like the most magical
sort of closet shopping experience
because you see things in reality that
you've ever only ever seen in picture
books and there is a huge difference
from seeing a photograph to seeing the
reality her ideas for the 2013 film The
Great Gatsby were inspired here you can
see that the gold changes color and won
her and Oscar we all know this dress
there's a good chance a dress that
dazzles this year's Met Gala red carpet
could end up here too with its own spot
in fashion history if you were a betting
man who's your money on tour the most
provocative dress code he beat maybe
well I'm curious to see which I was
wearing Lady Gaga Lady Gaga Lady gaga
amazing could it be maybe going off of
me heads ahead
you